what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
ranking every Titan shifter that we know
of from weakest to strongest I
previously did a video similar to this
in which I ranked the nine Titan ship
their powers rather than all of the
users if you want to know my thoughts on
which of the powers are strongest you
can check out that video in this one
we'll be looking at how well each user
uses his or her Titan power or powers
since some will have multiple we will
actually be ranking a whole 19 Titan
users so we got our work cut out for us
I'll also be looking at each Titan
shifter at their prime or strongest so
for instance I'll be looking at heir and
after the time skip and after all of his
power ups Before we jump into it a big
thank you to rave shadow legends for
sponsoring this video I've been playing
raid for a couple of months now and the
game is growing extremely fast there's a
huge update coming this month which will
be a lot of fun for new players so now
is definitely the best time to join the
fun in case you needed a reminder raid
Shadow Legends is a new collection
mobile RPG game with an amazing
storyline awesome 3d graphics giant boss
fights and more than 400 champions for
you to collect and personally customize
raid will remind you of classic RPG and
strategy games with the added bonus that
it's now on your phone this is the best
time to try this game out for free and
jump into the action if you go to the
description of this video right now and
download raid exclusively through my
link you will get 50,000 in silver
immediately you will also get a free
epic champion on top of that and just
see how crazy the level of detail is on
these champions try it out for yourself
right now the game is totally free on
Android and iOS just click the link in
the description for a free mobile game
raid Shadow Legends isn't a totally
different league and if you don't want
to take my word for it just check out
this almost perfect score in the Play
Store lastly keep in mind there will be
mind-blowing spoilers in this video if
you haven't read the manga you've been
warned remember this list is Maya
some of these users we haven't seen much
in action so we have to speculate to an
extent depending on the context to some
of these shifters could be more useful
than they are in terms of a head to head
fight but this is going to be focusing
on strength aka how they would fare in a
one-on-one battle against other Titans
on this list if they have access to all
their powers if you feel differently
about some of the rankings feel free to
let me know how you would rank the users
differently and why in the comments now
let's get to number 19 in 19th place we
have Tom Xavier the person who possessed
the beast Titan power before Reiner we
actually see Tom as early as chapter 87
but we get no context for him until
later in Chapter 114 he says that he is
a Marlin warrior but that he just plays
ball around the base because his beast
Titan isn't useful in a war his real job
is being a Titan science researcher we
knew for a while that Zeke was a
stronger beast Titan partially due to
his royal blood then previous beast
Titan users which is why they call him
the Boy Wonder
but we didn't know exactly how big that
gap was although we haven't seen Tom's
beast Titan in action I placed on here
because according to him his version of
the beast Titan wasn't even useful
enough in battle to be used by Marlay
against enemies all of the other Marlin
Titan shelters on this list were strong
enough to be used on the battlefield and
that is why Tom place is so low in 18th
place we have peak scar Titan I put the
car Titan in last place when I rank the
Titan powers from weakest to strongest
but still unlike Tom peek is used on the
battlefield peak scar Titan is very fast
it was able to catch Levi off-guard and
rescue Zeke from certain death because
of its insane speed her endurance is
through the roof she can maintain her
Titan form for at least two months her
Titan can also be equipped with
artillery which makes it able to deal
decent damage against other shifters
however to use these weapons Peake needs
the help of Marlin officers other Titan
shifters don't require this additional
help because they are strong enough
without military weapons as the Titans
name the car Titan implies piques Titan
is primarily you
for carrying things rather than for its
strength in one-on-one fight it's a
power that has proved to be very useful
in specific context but I believe that
the following Titan users will do better
in a one-on-one fight in 17th place we
got yamir from the survey Corps not to
be mistaken with the Emir the progenitor
who we'll get into later like the car
tighten the jaw tighten is really fast
combine its speed and agility with its
trademark sharp claws and jaws and you
get a fearsome opponent this Titan
fights even better within a forest where
it can swing around like Tarzan its
weakness is that it is small though it's
only 5 meters tall and was easily
overpowered by other Titans at earth
guard castle yamir was also not as good
with the power as other known users of
this Titan perhaps due to her lack of
training and experience for this reason
I couldn't put you mere as high as I put
the other known users of the jaw Titan
but I'll get to them later in 16th place
we got Frieda Reese who possessed the
strongest Titan power the power of the
founding Titan how could I put her this
low if she had the greatest of all Titan
powers well it can once again be blamed
on inexperience rod Reese tells us that
she lacked the experience necessary to
unleash the founding Titans true
abilities as a result she was defeated
and eaten by Grisha Yeager who possessed
the weaker power of the attack type
speaking of attack Titan in 15th place
we have Aaron Krueger's attack Titan we
didn't see Kruger go up against any
other Titans
we only saw him pick up and break a
marlin ship and kill many more lion
officers the attack titan is extremely
strong as being able to lift that ship
illustrates and it is noteworthy that
Kruger seems to have somehow known about
Mikasa and Armin as if he was able to
connect to Eren Yeager's memories from
the future however we haven't seen
enough from Kruger to place him any
higher on this list we never saw him
fight another Titan and because he had
to remain undercover he probably didn't
get to practice using his Titan powers
as much as some of the other shifters on
this list for these reasons he has to
stay at number 15 in 14th place we have
Grisha ager the guy who fathered both
the Zeke and Eren I put grish ahead of
Kruger for a few reasons
one
saw him take down an actual titan
shifter a possessor of the founding
titan no less he also potentially had
access to some of Krueger's memories in
addition to the memories of some other
past attack Titan users he combined his
own knowledge with the knowledge he gets
from these memories to get stronger
faster this is why I believe that
subsequent users have the potential to
get stronger eventually than previous
users because they can potentially learn
from the memories of past users albeit
this applies more to royal blooded
founding titan users who can see the
memories of past users with clarity
while other Titan shifters tend to only
get bits and pieces of memories from
their past users once in a while
lastly Grisha did have the founding
Titan in him in addition to the attack
Titan before he died the founding time
power can usually only be used by those
with royal blood but if a non royal
blooded Titan user has it they can still
use its powers if they come into contact
with the Titan of royal blood so if
krishna's opponent was a royal blooded
shifter like Zeke's beast Titan he would
be able to activate the founding Titan
powers there is also the possibility
that the founding titan can manifest its
abilities in different ways in non royal
blooded Titan shifters but we'll talk
more about that possibility when we get
to Eren Jaeger in 13th place we have
Reiner Braun and his version of the
armored Titan unlike many of the
previously mentioned Titan users Reiner
did go through extensive training with
his Titan the armored Titan specializes
in hardening abilities unlike other
Titans most of his Titan body is covered
in armor like plates which allow him to
effectively slam through most walls
doors and enemies his hardened fists
also make his punches much more
destructive another impressive thing is
that he can withstand the colossal
Titans explosion ability which we'll get
to later however I couldn't put him
higher for the following reasons first
his armor slows him down which wouldn't
be a huge deal if the armor was
indestructible but it's not at first a
less experienced Aaron was able to get
the upper hand on Reiner by using
fighting techniques he saw from a knee
which resemble moita Aaron uses
clinching techniques to actually break
riders armor when he learns how to
harden after drinking the armored Titan
serum Aaron is able to harden his fist
and break riders armor with punches
since most of the upcoming Titan
shifters I'll mention have a form of
hardening they would be able to
effectively break through riders armor
as a result the armor wouldn't be very
useful and would only serve to slow him
down in 12th place we have an eel Ellen
Hart the user of the female Titan and he
has great endurance when they get on the
island and he has to carry Reiner and
bertolt virtually the whole way to the
outer wall and she succeeds in doing so
furthermore she is able to run alongside
the horses of the survey Corps fight a
number of difficult opponents in the
Titan forest use vertical maneuvering
gear and human form to kill skilled
soldiers and turn into a Titan for a
second time and escape successfully and
he could also defeat Reiner using the
two methods that Aaron did Aaron copied
her fighting technique which Annie would
execute even better Plus and he has
hardening which she can combine with
destructive kicks and punches that
should be able to break through the
armor Titans defense for these reasons I
had to put a knee above Reiner on this
list in 11th and 10th place I have a tie
between the brothers Marcel and Porco
Galliard going off of your mears version
of the jaw Titan I never thought that
the jaw Titan could be all that strong
but after I saw Porco using its power I
had to give it a solid ranking on this
list during a flashback we see Marcel
using the jaw Titan which is described
as an assault unit its small size makes
it the swiftest of all and it's powerful
nails and jaws can crush just about
anything it was given to Marcel Galliard
initially in part because of how quick
witted he was furthermore Marcel was
singled out for being strong and he was
the leader among Reiner Annie and Bev
told as a result it stands to reason
that the jaw Titan power is supposed to
be a strong Titan power which is why
Marly reserved it for one of the
strongest warriors we saw that the jaw
tightened when the user knows how to
harden like Marcel and Galliard did has
the ability to break through the Titan
crystal that Annie and Willie Tibor
sister encased themselves in no other
Titan was able to do that combine that
ridiculously sharp and destructive
cutting power with the swiftness of all
the
itens and you get a deadly combination
that had to rank this high up on the
list
unfortunately Marcel sacrificed his life
for Reiner so we didn't get to see any
extremely impressive feats from him so I
couldn't put him above his brother Porco
even though he was seen as a better
warrior than his little brother
in contrast Porco was very impressive in
his fight against Aaron's attack Titan
after the time skip and Aaron even
needed me Casas helped to take him out
although he ended up being used as a
nutcracker
it took Aaron's attack Titan and an Opie
Ackerman to defeat him so since we can't
be sure if Marcel would have been as
impressive or more impressive in a
similar battle we'll just keep them tied
for the time being in 9th place we have
battled the user of the colossal Titan
also referred to as the god of
destruction power wise the colossal
Titan is insane in the guidebook he
scored exceptionally well in everything
except speed veg tolds colossal Titan
scored and off the charts 11 out of 10
in power 11 out of 10 in size a 10 out
of 10 in elusiveness a tenant up ten in
threat and it's only low score a three
out of 10 in speed reiner even tells
Berthold that the colossal Titan is
supposed to be the strongest Titan but
the timid and indecisive Berthold cannot
use the power to its full potential
because of this Zeke is considered
morally strongest warrior even though
the beast Titan should be weaker than
the colossal Titan the claws that can
create giant explosion land transforms
it can produce hot steam that can keep
Surrey corps members away from its nape
to compensate for its slow movements
because it is so huge though the 60
meter Titan cannot maintain its
transformation for as long as the other
Titans the main reason why Berthold
version of the colossal Titan is not
ranked higher on this list has less to
do with the colossal Titan shortcomings
and more to do with Berthold own
shortcomings as the user in a place we
have Marley's strongest warrior Zeke
Yeager the fact that Zeke could become
Marlay strongest warrior while Tom who
had the same time power wasn't even
useful enough to bring to battle speaks
to how important the specific shifter
can be when determining a titans power
Zeke is able to turn the
Titans throwing abilities into an
awe-inspiring weapon he can break up
rocks and launch them at enemies like
lethal bullets or he can throw a larger
rocks to do more concentrated damage his
aim is unrealistically good however his
most impressive power that is unique to
him because of his royal blood is his
ability to command Titans that were
created using his own spinal fluid this
is why the Marlins call Zeek the Boy
Wonder
although the control is not perfect as
it would be with the founding Titan
power what's impressive is that Zeek
easily defeats the armored Titan in his
beast Titan form when Reiner questions
his leadership while Aaron seemed to
struggle with Reiner in the past
it appears that Z can effortlessly take
him out and destroy his armor at will
for all these reasons Zeke's beast Titan
had to be this high up on the list in
seventh place we have Willie ty burrs
sister's version of the Warhammer Titan
the Warhammer Titan was the last of the
nine Titan powers that was revealed and
it was definitely worth the wait
when it appeared it was beating Aaron's
attack tighten until Mikasa the Opie
Ackerman showed up to lend a hand
even then Aaron needed to borrow the
sharp jaw of the JA titan to actually
defeat Willie's sister and absorb the
Warhammer Titan power for himself the
Warhammer Titan can create weapons using
its hardening powers anything from giant
spikes coming out of the ground to a
giant crossbow
furthermore it is much harder to defeat
than other Titans because the user
doesn't have to be in the nape of the
Titan the user can hide underground in
an almost indestructible crystal staying
completely safe while the Warhammer
Titan fights above ground so far we've
seen any anti burr sister in these
crystals and only the jaw Titan had the
power to cut through the material I
don't even think that the colossal
Titans explosions could break the
crystal since riders armored Titan is
able to withstand its explosion and his
armor is nowhere near as strong as these
crystals as a result Tiber sister could
easily wait out battles colossal Titan
until it runs out of steam and then
finish him off with her Warhammer Titan
all while staying safely inside her
crystal
its powers would also be effective
against the beast Titan since it could
form a shield or defensive wall to block
any rocks and even return long-range
attacks with various weapons like its
crossbow in a short-range battle with
all of its weapon choices the Warhammer
Titan should have a clear advantage
against the beast Titan who doesn't have
a way to destroy the users crystal for
all these reasons I had to put sister ty
burrs version of the Warhammer Titan
this high up on the list even if she was
defeated relatively quickly in the manga
in 6th place we have Arman's version of
the colossal Titan when Reiner told
betta told that he wasn't fully using
the colossal Titans power because of how
timid and indecisive he was the writer
was telling us that the colossal Titan
power could be much stronger in the
hands of the right person
well Armin was that person while
Berthold tends to need others to guide
him and come up with a plan for him
armin is the one that is usually coming
up with the plans that helped the survey
corps win and seemingly unwinnable
situations if it wasn't for his quick
thinking
Eren will not have been able to defeat
Berthold colossal Titan it was Armand's
intelligence that helped him defeat the
god of destruction and now that he has
that intelligence even more experience
and the power of the god of destruction
for himself he is undoubtedly one of the
strongest Titan shifters we've seen he
proved that he was willing to kill
others using the power when he used the
colossal Titans explosion ability to
destroy Malayan ships where bertolt was
lacking Armin excels and that is why
Army's version of the colossal Titan is
even stronger than Marley's strongest
warriors Zeke and his beast Titan I also
had to place our man above sister Tiber
because I believe they using his new
Titan powers his intelligence and his
quick thinking he could potentially come
up with a plan to beat her in fifth
place we have Aaron currently the
possessor of the attack Titan founding
Titan and war hammer Titan if one Titan
power makes you strong then you can only
imagine how strong three Titan powers
makes you in his Titan form Aaron was
able to hold his own against the armored
Titan the jaw Titan and the car Titan
and the firepower die was equipped to it
in Chapter one
17 Aaron still seems fine by the time
Zeke shows up who congratulate him on
holding out on his own against the
Marlon Army and their three Titans he
can now combine the impressive strength
of the attack titan with the weapons and
versatility of the opie Warhammer Titan
power if Zeke is there or if he is
taking on a royal blood and Titan he
could even use the Opie founding Titan
powers however he may be able to benefit
from the founding Titan inside him even
if he doesn't have royal blood
Deanna may only part where eren's Titan
entered berserk mode and crushed a knee
might be an ability associated with the
founding titan that comes into effect
kind of like the Avatar state when
certain conditions are met then again
that might be a power associate with the
attack tightened to a form that helps to
use to keep moving towards freedom no
matter what furthermore if Aaron gets a
handle on that telling the Future power
which Krueger's seemed to get a glimpse
of he may well be able to use that to
better prepare for future battles Aaron
was already Opie before the Warhammer
Titan even with little experience he
could beat riders armored Titan but now
his Titan is in my view the strongest
living Titan Armin's colossal Titan is
strong and smart but even he would have
trouble overcoming Aaron's versatile
powers some of which are still a mystery
in 4th 3rd and 2nd we have previously
royal blooded users of the strongest
Titan power the power of the founding
titan 3 users from weakest to strongest
are rod rhesus dad rod rhesus brother
URI and the first king of the walls Carl
Prince as rod Reese explains in chapter
63 the founding Titan is not only the
greatest of all the Titans it also
possesses an invincible power all of
these users were royal blooded and we
can assume they lived long enough to
learn how to use the powers of the
founding Titan which include controlling
Titans even the colossal Titans inside
the walls changing memories or bodies of
LD ends and perfect knowledge of past
users and in turn of the history of the
world because of all these powers the
founding Titan user has been compared to
a God who gets
determine the fate of humanity since
controlling the colossal Titans in the
walls is a part of the founding Titans
powers it must be counted as a factor in
a one-on-one match but it may not be
necessary
a royal blooded founding Titan may even
be able to shape the memories control
the movements or even reshape the bodies
of other Titan shifters for all these
reasons these guys have to be considered
even stronger than Eren currently is
none of the previously mentioned Titan
shifters could hope to take on the
countless colossal Titans inside the
three walls Rodri says that I ranked as
the weakest because we did not get to
see his founding Titan powers in action
Yuri did use his powers to completely
overpower an Ackerman no small
accomplishment so I had to put him above
his father who has no known
accomplishments to speak up
Carl Fritz's accomplishments are on a
whole nother level he manipulated
countless people's memories he formed
the walls by controlling all those
colossal Titans and he had the power to
pass on his philosophy to future royal
blooded users of the founding Titan
power these accomplishments have to put
him above the other two users on this
list in first place we have the woman
who started it all yamir fritz
the nine titan powers were all inside
her at one point before she split them
into nine different powers this is by
far the easiest time-shifter to rank
because we are even told by Aaron that
the founding Titan died thirteen years
after first awakening to her powers and
Nolan's power can exceed hers this is
why no Titan shifter can live over 13
years after awakening their Titan power
that's how your mirrors curse works so
we know that she possessed all the best
aspects of every Titan power and that
her power cannot be exceeded perhaps the
only chance of anyone approaching Ymir's
power is if Aaron or someone with royal
blood succeeded in gathering all nine
Titan powers inside of themselves but
until that happens no one on this list
even comes close to you mirrors power it
is worth mentioning that according to
some stories
Jameer got her Titan powers from the
earth devil but whether the earth devil
was a Titan himself or what
he even actually existed is unknown so I
decided not to include him in this list
if he was real though he gave you me or
her Titan powers so you could imagine
that he was even stronger than her and
that is it for today's video thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed the
video make sure to smash that like
button and let me know if you haven't
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you get notified when future attack
on Titan videos come out in the comments
you can let me know what type of attack
on Titan videos you'd really like to see
in the future and thanks again to Rage
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
definitely check out this amazing game
link in the description thank you for
all the support and until next time see
you space cowboys
[Music]